the president has never felt that title
42 was
a an effective immigration policy and he
talked about that during the campaign
the white house basically saying that
title 42 is useless
after a federal judge issued a temporary
restraining order on biden's plan to end
the trump-era border policy that has
been massively effective at stopping
migrants that comes as the fallout
continues from the tragic death of
22-year-old texas national guardsman
bishop evans who drowned while trying to
save migrants in the rio grande river
while the white house tries to deny any
responsibility for the death dismissing
him as a state employee
texas governor greg abbott is making it
clear who's at fault
we would not have to have the national
guard on the border if the bad
administration was very simply enforcing
the laws passed by the united states
congress and securing our border
i think i said this a couple months ago
so people are going to start dying
and it's going to move public opinion
it's i'm you know our border patrol our
national guardsmen uh the first
responders there that are on the border
that work for the
state government or even the local
governments they've done amazing work
think of the children that they save the
babies that they save you only hear
about the very tragic situations like
with bishop evans because it went so
wrong for him and
sometimes a government official will say
something that takes your breath away
and
the
the thought that he was just a state
employee so that's being dismissive
i don't think that was necessarily
intended but it came across as very
crass yeah and i don't it was totally
not intended she didn't she didn't want
it well why would you say it and why why
say it anyway then that's yeah
it looked like it was a little bit of a
dig
at governor abbott there was there's a
way to say nothing there
i think that the title 42 is headed in
the same direction as so many other
things that the biden administration has
tried which is they put out a policy or
they try to hide behind a policy and
then the courts strike it down you had
your deportation moratorium remain in
mexico vaccine mandates eviction
moratorium remember that one the freeze
on oil and gas leases all the things
that they're trying basically get
stopped by the courts and then they're
like oh sorry to the left like oh sorry
so this is this is a
a lawless president because i remember
any time trump did something that got
struck down lawless president geraldo
you look like you were chomping at the
bit to get after the story you thought
more about your policy no i i
policy is one thing jesse but when you
when you get to be my age and you look
at these pictures and you see these
people
you know what what's the policy when you
see that the
the babies and you know they desperately
want what america promises they uh
i used to be the uh latin american
correspondent for abc did all the work
down there every country all those wars
in the central america and all that
they really have the short end of the
stick you know i feel so sorry for them
i understand america can't take
everybody uh but i wanna i did a bad job
explaining
codification of title 42 yesterday i
wanted one more short crack at it
what the courts have now said you can't
end title 42 and you can't end
remain in mexico the courts one two
different courts have now enjoined those
votes the
republicans in congress are pressing the
democrats to make a law that
accomplishes the result of remaining in
mexico which makes sense they come
through mexico
to claim asylum here let them
let them stay in mexico when they're
silent i understand the rationale for it
may not be 100 behind it but i
understand the rationale for it but you
need laws executive orders come and go
one administration has one thing the
next administration has said when you
have a law and the law has been tested
uh in court constitutionally that's the
only way we need comprehensive
immigration reform
our hearts are gonna keep breaking and
terrible cases are gonna happen
you're shaking your head now yeah no we
don't need compressive immigration
reform we need people to follow the law
how do you stop joe how do you stop them
how about you put border patrol
where are you come on wait a minute
can you ask me a question let me answer
it sorry you stop them by making by
having a ball a wall that's number one
but that's not going to work you stop
them by doing everything that joe biden
is not doing joe biden is doing
everything he can to bring everyone
everyone to make united states a global
landing spot where everyone who pays
taxes gets to pay for all their
education medication housing food
whatever they want okay let me tell you
what he's doing he's not just leaving
the border open he is actually
instituting policies to make it easier
for them to get in so you don't hold
them you give them an alternative to
detention an atd you give them a notice
to appear an nta you give them a cell
phone and then you provide them with
with the uh the ability to go into the
interior of the country you don't go to
court to fight to lift title 42 that
allows them to return illegals you go to
court to fight against it and in doing
so you allow in unvaccinated illegals
and fight in court for their right to
come in unvaccinated while at the same
time you appeal a decision by a federal
judge that that says we don't have to
wear mass appealing that decision saying
i want you americans to wear masks okay
but wait a minute but while they are now
in the supreme court fighting to end the
remain of mexico policy which forces
them to stay in mexico this
administration is doing everything it
can to change america to do everything
it can to put a burden on all of us and
stop with this poor then for them for
them okay they could come here legally
like my family came here legally all
right they respected this country when
my family came you know what we're
lebanese when we came they they kissed
the ground of the united states my
father fought in world war ii my
grandfather fought in world war ii they
couldn't wait to defend this country so
stop with this hogwash you to tried
try to send them home and they will kick
and scream that they don't want to go
home stop with the hogwash geraldo
greg go ahead don't you even have any
compassion i have more compassion in my
little pinky geraldo go ahead greg
i'm tired yeah that was kind of
exhausting i i think this is a running
problem if you look at like the first
segment on twitter musk in this segment
on the border and then we're going to do
crime
the modern democratic party stakes out
their positions
knowing that they are destructive simply
because they can't be seen agreeing with
the other side so
they build their own little prison
by demonizing everybody else outside of
it if we were against the wall they
would have been for it if there was a
republican in charge right now in a
parallel universe they would be
plastering this story around the clock
they would be talking about the dead the
dead texas national guardsmen as
something that you know is is is they
would they would treat it like a huge
story but they can't be seen in bed with
republicans they can't be seen agreeing
with us
so instead what they do is they just
they throw compassion out the window
they i mean the way she answered jen
sackey answered that question yesterday
was like not our fault that's on them
even though she knew for two years that
this has been a problem and they didn't
do anything about it so they're
they're willing to actually sacrifice
people uh at the at this altar of
political separateness yeah we can have
compassion for everybody geraldo but we
have to have compassion for americans
first i went on brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now